hey youtubers it's Charlie so a bunch of
you guys requested I do like a recap of
everything that's happened on Game of
Thrones so far that would be like a six
hour video so I'm gonna do like a super
recap from season 1 to season 4 because
the HBO now service is also available
I'm giving away to iTunes gift cards for
like the first month free you basically
get the first month free anyway but all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so just spoiler warning for
everything on Game of Thrones so far
starting with season 1 here we go
so for the first season it had a very
much Lannisters versus Starks motif even
though there were many many great houses
and a lot of big players in the east but
we pick up at Winterfell we meet the
Starks we meet the direwolves and then
we meet the king and his family of
Lannisters some of them secret twincest
Lannisters most notable early WTFs
include a teaser for the White Walkers
quite a way to open the show you barely
see them big takeaway I saw bees roaming
around in the north and no one believes
the Nights Watch deserter who Ned Stark
ends up killing clearly something going
on up there but they won't really
address it for a while that was way up
in the haunted forest up north of Castle
black here Winterfell is just a little
bit south of there and within the first
20 minutes of the pilot we meet most of
the main cast including Lannister's
Baratheon's over in the east we meet
Daenerys her brother Viserys and then
Khal Drogo three very very important
people the show almost picks up in like
a post adventure setting as in like this
huge adventure had happened and everyone
had gone to seed like nothing had
happened there'd been a long summer
seasons last for different durations so
when people say winter is coming it's
coming after an extremely long summer
that lasted many many many years Robert
Baratheon took the throne from the
Targaryen Daenerys and Viserys over here
their father and has been ruling himself
into his own grave ever since laying
bastards all over the kingdom every
chance he gets Ned and Robert our old
friends and Robert had come to
Winterfell to the Starks home to ask Ned
to become his chief advisor at the hand
of the king Ned reluctantly accepts and
they all make their way back to King's
Landing down here over in the east
Daenerys brother Viserys is trying to
take back the throne but he needs an
army so he's going to marry Daenerys to
Khal Drogo so Dee gains his khalasar of
40,000 warriors so bagging King's
Landing because
Ned has become hand of the king they
betrothed Ned Stark's oldest daughter
Sansa Stark to Joffrey Baratheon
the current heir to the throne the
majority the plot in King's Landing in
season 1 is all about Ned Stark slowly
uncovering that Joffrey is secretly
Cersei and Jaime Lannister's son a lot
of people get killed in the biggest WTF
of the season was Ned Stark eventually
getting his head chopped off Robert died
during the season so Joffrey ascended to
the throne
turns out he's a monster and ends up
having Ned Stark beheaded thus begins
the war of the five kings which takes us
into season two for the most part for
the first couple of seasons Game of
Thrones went from book to book as it
went from season to season so season two
is mostly book to stuff season two is
all about setting up the idea that
several people in the Seven Kingdoms
feel like they have a claim to the
throne in addition to obviously Daenerys
over in the east Roberts brothers
Stannis becomes a major antagonist
against King's Landing
then there's Robb Stark who becomes Lord
of Winterfell after his father Ned Stark
was beheaded they're so pissed about
what happened to Ned that they declare
war against the Lannisters technically
it's against the throne because they're
going after Joffrey they want Joffrey's
head so they're mostly going after
Lannisters because they believe that
Joffrey is a Lannister even though at
this point it's not common knowledge
every everyone in the kingdom isn't
saying it out loud
Daenerys in the East has also become a
growing force at the end of season one
she hatched three new dragons who were
believed to have been gone from the
world forever she takes over Khal
Drogo's khalasar but but it's slowly
falling apart
dragons have a very deep connection to
magic you know no matter what mythology
you're talking about so the minute they
appeared on screen it was like a visual
reminder that magic does exist in this
world so throughout the season you start
to see more evidence of magic
Melisandre makes a smoked baby was one
of the big early WTS of the season and
eventually later we see an army of White
Walkers so you get the sense that there
is a greater war going on in the
background that most of the main
characters don't realize you have the
red God and the great other the god of
the White Walkers on the other side of
that coin most of the people in Westeros
are just worried about fighting each
other at the war of the five kings
Stannis amasses an army of ships all the
way up here at Dragonstone where he's
stationed takes them to King's Landing
and you have one of the greatest battles
in Game of Thrones history the Battle of
black
water the really fun part about the
battle is we get to see Tyrion concoct
an elaborate plan using wildfire that
opens the alchemy door in the Game of
Thrones universe it really expands the
lore in a fun way
wildfire is a lot like Greek fire and
that you can't put it out with water
it'll just spread over the top of water
everyone almost gets roasted alive and
we get one of the most famous lines from
the show the king just a reminder that
loyalty on the show is fleeting
eventually in the East Daenerys finds a
renewed sense of purpose as her dragons
continue to grow she goes into a place
called the house of the undying and has
several visions of things that may come
to pass or things that may have come to
pass had things in the past been
different the way visions work on Game
of Thrones is very weird sometimes
you're seeing things that might have
happened had things gone differently and
sometimes you're seeing things that
could still happen this is also the
season that we got to meet the Greyjoy
is in a much bigger way they don't
appear too often but they're over here
on the Iron Islands reaving and raping
their way all along the coast as their
ancestors did as we move into season 3
we see the war of the five kings slowly
abating just a little bit Robb Stark has
done a really good job he's a great
battle master but things are just
starting to fall apart all over the
place up in the north the Greyjoy's have
taken Winterfell or Theon Greyjoy in the
name of the Greyjoy's Stannis Baratheon
army has been shattered in Tywin
Lannister marches back into King's
Landing arguably the most fearsome man
in all of Westeros you could also call
him the most powerful man and the
richest man although all those things go
hand in hand we still think of the
Starks and the Lannisters is like the
two big forces but at this point we meet
some of the other big houses most
notably the Tyrells aside from the
Lannisters they're the other richest
house in Westeros
the Lannisters have their gold mines the
Tyrells have their land they just have
massive amounts of land up in the north
- Jon Snow is running counter
intelligence against the wildlings like
another big force of people living north
of the wall he spends most of the season
with them falls in love with Ygritte one
of the best females in the show as you'd
expect things go pretty bad for him and
he ends up coming back eventually not
before though one of the best visual
effects sequences the show has ever had
the wildlings climbing up the wall a 600
foot high wall of ice you also see like
the the birth of one of the best pairs
of characters on the show Jaime and
Brienne Brienne is trying to help the
by using Jamie Lannister to barter for
ones that are still left in King's
Landing
remember the more the five Kings is
still going on so Lannister's still very
much at war with the Starks then of
course we get to probably like the
biggest moment on television that year
the red wedding if you're not familiar
with the red wedding the name of the
episode is actually the rains of
castamere it's actually been turned into
the Lannister theme so any time there
are Lannisters on screen you can softly
hear the rains of castamere tune playing
in the background the red wedding refers
to an event whereby the phrase in
concert with the Lannisters in the
throne kill Robb Stark and pretty much
all of his army at the twins here at a
dinner they had been invited for a
wedding Robb Stark was supposed to marry
one of the phrase daughters he derped
married someone else for love pissed the
phrase off
so the phrase allied themselves with the
Lannisters and agreed to kill Robb Stark
and everyone with him the characters on
the show get killed off all the time but
in the red wedding it was several big
characters all within the span of a
couple minutes of each other one of the
really fun sayings from the show and
from the books is that the North
remembers so remember even though a lot
of starts died that day there's several
that are still alive and will eventually
get their revenge over in the East
Daenerys is finally amassed an army she
starts to liberate slaves
so she's hailed as the mother of dragons
because of her three dragons and as the
mother of this big group of people that
she's liberated it's a fun twist because
Targaryens are typically thought of as
really fearsome people and she's being
thought of in this really benevolent way
so now we're moving into season four and
instead of having like you know one or
two really big WTF moments like climbing
the wall or the red wedding there are
several big WTF spread out throughout
the season we also get to meet one of
the most interesting characters that the
show's ever had Oberyn Martell here
they're from the South in Dorne a place
that we haven't seen yet house Martell
in an interesting twist are bitter
enemies of House Lannister
we don't really explore that too much
until the end of the season Oberyn
Martell is trying to solve the mystery
of his sister's murder she was wife of
Rhaegar Targaryen who was killed during
Robert's rebellion he finds out that the
man who killed her is the mountain here
the champion of Tywin Lannister he wants
to kill a bunch of people most notably
Lannisters but the mountain ends up
becoming the first person on the list
Oberyn Martell vs. Gregor
cocaine probably the best fight all
season they fought in a trial by combat
by way of the purple wedding that's
another red wedding level event and the
interesting thing that the show didn't
convey is is that in the timeline of the
books it actually happened relatively
close to the red wedding it was almost
like george RR martin was trying to help
the fans out he killed all these amazing
stark characters that everyone loved so
much and he had to answer it by killing
off Joffrey Lannister even though the
Starks had absolutely nothing to do with
it for that we have to thank the queen
of thorns working with Littlefinger so
Joffrey dies Tyrion gets blamed thrown
in the black cells and ends up leading
to a trial by combat Oberyn becomes
Terriers champion that's how he got in
the fight with the mountain he loses so
that means that Tyrion is going to be
executed but he is rescued by his
brother working with Varys instead of
going straight out he actually goes up
to his father's chambers he's gonna try
and kill his father finds his longtime
lover Shae in his bed ends up killing
them both
Shae was a really sad death even if he
didn't like the character but him
killing Tywin on the [ __ ] was
probably one of the most fun deaths all
season and a huge WTF so as the story is
moving along things keep growing and
growing up at the wall we have an army
of wildlings that are marching on the
wall marching on Castle black as the
battle reaches its epic climax Stannis
comes riding in with a new army of cell
swords that he's acquired they make
quick work of the wildlings who
surrender so we're left with a bunch of
characters that are gonna try and figure
out what to do after this big battle at
the start of season 5 over in the east
Daenerys has now used her army to take
control of one of the biggest cities in
the area Marine she finds though that
there's a big difference between
liberating a group of people and ruling
them in a very effective way it's like
what do you do after the battle is done
what does it mean to be a real Queen and
by this time her dragons are so big that
they become a huge problem they start
eating people so she is forced to lock
two of them up the other one drogon is
flying around at free will he can't be
captured so he literally continues to
become a bigger and bigger problem
physically and metaphorically so that
brings us to season five we're gonna see
like a couple really big new places new
locations and a new big family that we
haven't met yet the Martel's are one of
the most powerful families in Westeros
the
Joe hasn't done a lot with yet we saw
oberyn martell in season 4 but he was
just like the tip of the iceberg
then bringing Dorn into the story
required them to go to a whole new
filming location it just it looks vastly
diverse from what we've seen before
through and through one of the most fun
things is is that from season to season
all the alliances change so characters
that were best friends in one season
hate each other in the next you know
just because Tyrion is a Lannister
doesn't mean that his family isn't
gunning for him still after the death of
Joffrey in the background - we still
have the White Walkers and the red god
they're gonna continue to be a really
big thing especially up at this other
new location hardhome be very excited
for special white Walker stuff to happen
up here so impregnated X's do like a
deep dive into a group of characters
like the Martel's
or maybe Arya Stark that'll probably
post on Saturday like in between
daredevil videos so be sure to subscribe
to get that I'll announce the winners of
the HBO now giveaway whenever I post
that just in case you're finding me for
the first time what I'm gonna do on
Sunday for the premiere is do a new
bonus video early in the day and then
I'll post my episode review after
episode 1 airs when that episode posts
the giveaway for that video is gonna be
two signed copies of a feast for crows
and a dance of dragons both signed by
george RR martin and i'll ship them
anywhere in the world so it doesn't
matter it's open to international people
after that week two week the giveaway
will just be either Amazon giftcards or
HBO now subscription is just just
depending on what your preference is so
if you guys have any questions about
about the giveaways or you have any
requests for bonus videos week to week
cuz I will do bonus videos every week
just be sure to leave them in the
comments it's gonna be a really fun
season there will be a lot of changes
from the books so as I do my episode
reviews I'll try to explain what is
different from the books whenever it
happens if you do have the HBO now
service you can also you can watch every
single episode of Game of Thrones on
demand just like Netflix why you guys
wait for my next game of Thrones bonus
video and for a daredevil to drop you
can click here for all my other season 5
videos I just did a Sansa video and you
can click here for my non-spoilery
daredevil episode 1 review so that's all
dropping at midnight get excited
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys a little bit
you
[Music]